honeybee would come from me sing on the
couch and i was like honey boo boo child
and from there on out it just stopped
alana thompson aka honey boo boo is all
grown up with a glam new look the
reality star who rose to fame on tlc's
toddlers and tiaras turns 16 on august
28th and is showing off another side in
a new glamorous spread with teen vogue
my style it is the best out there i'm
the drippiest person ever alana was
dripping for the photo shoot in several
sophisticated looks wearing gucci
elloquie and tiffany and co
in the interview the high school student
opens up about the difficulties of
growing up in the spotlight and wants
fans to know she's not honey boo boo
telling the mag quote my mama did not
name me honey boo boo my name is alana
[Music]
alana also dished on her excitement over
turning 16 and getting her driver's
license i guess i can drive now yep kind
of like a lamborghini or something you
know some fast you know
she has fast and expensive taste
speaking of alana made her signature
go-go juice
and it still hits the spot let me give
y'all my secret recipe
how much ever that is
i guess that's enough
that's delicious
alana has come a long way since her
pageant days now she goes to public
school and works on weekends and after
school she even reveals what she wants
to do for a career when i grow up i want
to be a neato nato nurse until then
she's still a teenager with a boyfriend
who she says is her only friend she told
the mag quote to be honest i do not have
many friends at all because i feel like
folks are so much like oh my god i'm
friends with honey boo boo i don't trust
nobody really so i don't have friends a
lot of people think i'm just like a
stuck-up celebrity when i'm really just
cool and a really fun person to be
around e.t sat down with alana her
sister pumpkin and their mom june mama
june shannon in may where they dished on
alana's boyfriend and if he has their
stamp of approval she does have a little
boyfriend who like comes over and stuff
like he comes over for like dinners and
stuff very respectful
so it is nice to he comes to family
dinners yes he does so everyone approves
of him
it's good having a boyfriend i like it
but when it comes to their future on
reality tv after a decade of cameras
following the family around mama june
says their time may be coming to an end
we honestly think our life is kind of
boring even though our life is always
crazy and chaotic
but you know there's been those fans
that's loved us
there and in between
and in a way i do feel like it may be
close to the time for us to just to kind
of
kind of
the kardashians bow out and say thank
you we appreciate it
you know we may have like one more
season in us um and then i don't think
that you know
at that point what more is there that
film
[Music]